welcome to of red pills production vlogs
so today is November 20th and yesterday
we found out that we got one of the
story hat grants which is kind of
phenomenal but we had done some meeting
stuff and we decided we're actually
going to go check out some studio spaces
right now
get a good idea of what is available yes
and to do that we're going to M TM I
usually wrench through them like I've
rented a lot of equipment through them
over the years but I've never I've never
really had an opportunity to use the
studio space because it's a lot of money
it's a lot of money yeah particularly
the big space you know I mean it's not
it's not absorbent but it's it's more
it's not free either and this is sort of
the crazy thing this is the thing that
I've outlined that I'm super excited
about with with this is that I've worked
on a ton of my own stuff before like my
own ideas and whatnot I've worked on a
ton of projects and productions with
budgets but those have never been the
same thing you know so this is the first
time that I'm working on my own stuff
with the budget
or like with a budget that is not like
hey I've got 800 bucks that I set aside
you know let's make this go as far as
possible this is you know actually yeah
ten thousand dollars it's someone else's
money yeah well it's our money it's our
money now but it's like it's not you
know it's not our own pocket grater
we're being it's it's a grants I mean it
is a great it's a great yeah we've got a
grant we have grant money
which is government mandated grant money
from telecommunications industry it's
wonderful it is wonderful you know if I
have appreciate
there's a lot of there's a lot of
back-and-forth like we talk with people
just a lot of back and forth about sorry
high evidence its value and its flaws
and it certainly has flaws but what I
appreciate is that it's it's not just
the same process as every other grant
out there you know and this is not a
slam against those grants it's just that
it's it's nice that there's a little bit
of variety in the application process in
the awarding process and just in the way
that you engage with the grants because
so many of them
it's alright fill out a bunch of
paperwork send it in and if you did it
right maybe they contact you for more
information generally you only hear back
to either again you know
approval or refusal so having this
different process like even though it
comes with its own flaws and its own you
know it's different set of flaws it's
still a different set of claws it's
still a different set of
strengths as well so
you know yeah because there isn't going
to be there's going to be there is no
perfect way of handing out money you
know there there is no perfect way of
making sure that the the best projects
or the most rewarding valuable projects
are going to get it because how do you
even decide that like is is the project
that is most likely to succeed the most
valuable or is the project that will
give its casting crew the most
experience the most value you know value
comes down so much too
these these individual goals and
individual rewards that it's like you
know
there's kind of that question level
what's the purpose of various grants and
so you really do need them to cover a
lot of different types and styles in
order to ensure that you know you're
getting production monies of people who
need to experiment and learn and you're
also getting production money to people
who are already skilled and talented but
need chances to get their work actually
made great which is a very rare
opportunity sometimes yeah you know
there's there's so much in the way that
the that the industry is constructed
that is very it's very conservative and
I mean that in the sense that it doesn't
take a lot of huge risks and that's a
big reason wise or government money or
government mandated money is is so
important because there's not a lot of
private investors who are willing to to
take those kinds of risks on unproven
talent so you end up in a situation
where basically the people who have
managed to get
are the people who keep getting kicked
over and over and over again because
they have proven themselves so you need
to be proven in order to get hired but
you need to be out hired in order to get
proven
so on and so forth
so yeah so programs like this that
enable you know more people to get their
stuff out there get proven get you know
have a have a crack at making something
that you know has a lot fewer
restrictions on it
and the $10,000 is is not a lot of money
when it comes to production particularly
when you're going to be like when you
want to be paying the people who you're
hiring $10,000 tries up very quickly but
it's an F it's kind of it's a really
good amount because it it won't let you
do everything but it will let you do
something that you otherwise probably
like could not could not pull off on
your own right
which is why this experience is pretty
new yeah because this you know this is
exactly the sort of thing
hiring out a studio hiring out studio
space is is not the kind of thing that I
would normally be able to justify I just
wouldn't have the money right
and the reality is specifically in
Canada as well that's more common than
not
we support we're part of this
well within the idea that private
investing oh yeah yeah and Canada as
well just because the yeah because the
the industry is smaller you know there's
the largest the largest Canadian
productions are like five million
dollars and five million dollars is
jamming the Holograms in the States
yeah you know which is just kind of this
like cheap mid-weight not even like when
we consider it a blockbuster is just a
cheap mid weighing kind of filler that
they push out but that in Canada and a
five million dollar budget is a huge
freaking deal like I think Passchendaele
is like 13 million yeah it's one of the
biggest Canadian productions ever made
yeah and 13 million is like the catering
budget on transformers basically
so what do we learn alright so we had
our meeting had our little meeting at
MTM and the space is perfect it's big
enough they've got all of the support
stuff that we need but they're also
super busy so we're going to send them
an email and hopefully hopefully
hopefully hopefully they can squeeze us
in two days right after New Year's which
is a little further out then I was
hoping to shoot but it's still not too
far
it gives us a nice relaxed sort of
pre-production pre-production time and
still more than enough time for
post-production but there's there's a
chance that they might have zero days
available until February which will not
do which would not work so we also need
to start thinking about contingencies in
terms of space and locations so looking
for things like an airplane hangar or a
warehouse or
an arena or something something of sort
of comparable size otherwise we might
need to get kind of really radical with
this and maybe look into a space that is
not as big but is you know like maybe
something that's just really long like a
space that's just really long rather
than one that's also tall and you know
so that's kind of that's kind of the
thought process right now and no it was
good but really hoping I really hope
they've got they've got space
unfortunately I couldn't get even though
I talked to them earlier I couldn't look
anything earlier because I could I
didn't you know know well this is day
one this is day one so so we we did this
right yeah you know and this is why
planning is so important and getting on
the ball ASAP is important and leaving
yourself time to problem-solve oh man
like if we had waited a week on this and
midlist ago well we'll go talk to MTM
like we'll go talk to them in a week or
two like closer to closure just like no
no get that done like right away that's
that's a big ticket thing that's one
that you got to get nailed down so no so
I'm glad I'm very glad that we made made
this trip and learned that information
and I'm really hoping that it works out
I'm really hoping that they've got those
they can do those two days for us
because they're here in town they're
accessible they've got all the gear kind
of right there so you can even do like
pretzels kind of ala carte if you're in
the middle of the day and it's like I
crap we need a you know we need a joker
just just walk right next-door and print
a joker
so that's our right by the way it's a
type of light yeah so it's it's good in
that regard and they've got the dolly
and they've got the track there and and
that's sort of that's one of the big
things like only needing to move dolly
and track next door as opposed to
needing to like transport it somewhere
that's that's huge because it's big it's
unwieldy it's heavy yeah you know the
transportation logistics of moving dolly
and track like that alone like we
already have to worry about the
transportation logistics of set um if we
had to add a pile a giant pile of gear
on top of that it's gonna get rough yeah
but go fingers fingers are cropping Gers
crossed it's a little hard with the
gloves on
yeah can in canadian problems